we're joined right here but one by one
of our favorites i truly always love
talking to this man always a fascinating
chat because it's not just about
football
and always has been more than just a
game for this man and now uh he
announced today
that he is a retired football player
two-time super bowl champion three-time
pro bowler 13 seasons in the nfl 14th
overall pick of the 2009 nfl draft on
the mercedes-benz vans phone line
malcolm jenkins on the program how you
doing malcolm
i'm doing good rich how you doing i'm
doing i'm doing great um
all right uh i i i knew you
i'm i'm so
first of all i'm very appreciative that
you you know that i'm part of your your
day um
in which this announcement uh
got out um that you made it so why why
now malcolm jenkins
for you well you know i think for me
um
you know every year i i came into the
league you know wanting to get to 10
years right knowing that that
is what i thought a respectable career
was um
and realistically you realize how hard
that is to accomplish but when i look
back over the 13 seasons you know i i've
come i've done what i came to do you
know in this league and i think
it the cost of playing at a high level
at least for me it takes
it takes me sacrificing
you know my time my body my energy i put
everything i have into the game
um
and that's just how i'm wired and so
i've been doing it so long for the game
that i'm actually the last five years
i've really been
building kind of my team and you know my
businesses and other interests and
investing in different parts of who i am
as a person
and i just am ready to now do something
else like i'm ready to put that same
drive and energy that people know me for
on the football field and put it towards
you know uh other aspects of you know my
life my businesses uh and my other
interests and obviously my family you
know i got two
two little girls who you know are
playing sports now and doing all these
things and and while they probably enjoy
coming to my games you know i'm enjoying
going to theirs and being around more
and being able to raise you know my kids
the way that i want um all of that you
know
leads me to the tough decision of
letting go of the game that i've been
playing since you know i was seven years
old but i think
based on all the things i've done in
life that i've accomplished i've at
least
gotten to this point and know that i am
blessed and
grateful and
and privileged really to be able to walk
away from the game on my own accord that
that isn't really afforded to many
people in this sport and professional
sports in general and so i'm extremely
grateful for the game i'm humbled by the
people i've met along the way the cities
that i've been a part of the franchises
all of that has made me who i am today
well and and you just mentioned about
you know the longevity and the really
impressive part about it too i have an
nfl network sent out to all of us a you
know a package of statistics once you
made your announcement malcolm
and the one thing that just leaps out to
me is since 2014 okay so the the second
half of your career you're one of only
six players to start 128 games in the
nfl
and you're tops by far in terms of
safeties and passes defensed in that
time period
so what what did you do to have to get
ready that you're kind of
now uh pleased to have in your rear view
mirror
to have that sort of longevity
yeah i think you know longevity we talk
about in our league all the time you
know accountability and availability
availability being the two things that
you know every successful player has to
have
um and availability so oftentimes is out
of players control you know injuries are
part of the game we've seen careers
altered or ended uh over and over again
due to injuries the violent nature of
what we do
um and so i've been extremely lucky to
not have any of those you know major
injuries and then
but also you know i put a lot of work
into my body and preparing
for the long season to be able to not
only
um survive it but to thrive in it and
and i've definitely you know put into
work knowing that i'm an integral part
of every team or have been an integral
part of every team that i've been on and
me not being available is also hurting a
team and at least that's how i was
raised when i came in the league and
that's what i have kind of you know
always stood on and to be able to look
at
how many games play how many snaps were
played
um
you know last year i missed the first
game since i missed the game it was the
first time i missed the game since 2013.
and i missed it due to covet you know
i'm not even hurt and so it's
it's one of those things that i i look
back and i realize i'm extremely blessed
and after 13 years every time i start
touching the field you're like ah you're
wondering if my luck is going to run up
but man i'm glad to walk away from this
game with my my mind intact my body
attack uh i feel good and that's
you know as a player that's all you can
ask for absolutely and then of course to
have the career that you had the 13-year
career that you have malcolm jenkins
here on the rich eisen show uh 99-yard
pick six still holds a record for
you know longest in the nfl who'd you
pick off for that one
i believe he went to your school uh it
was good
one of my favorite favorite uh opponents
the great goat tom brady
you picked off and by the way you're the
only human being i think i laid this on
you on live nfl network television when
you stopped by the super bowl set a
couple years ago only human to win a
super bowl against both brady and peyton
manning you picked off eli manning twice
in the same game if i'm not mistaken you
you won big game hunting in your career
malcolm
i said it's funny i tell people all the
time they asked me who who was the who
what quarterback gave you the most
trouble and i'm like honestly i have a
winning record versus brady i've had
some really good games against him
um
eli i've played against he's probably my
favorite quarterback to play against he
threw me a couple in the game that was
my favorite game after me too
did we beat peyton manning in the in the
super bowl aaron rodgers you know we
just
beat him up in the opener last year you
know i've had success against the the
big names but the guys who've given me
the most problems in my career like kirk
cousins
and ryan fitzpatrick every time i played
them they do probably 400 yards well i
mean ryan fitzpatrick because he's not
ashamed to throw it in any window even
if he should be going everywhere yeah
that's difficult to defend you know if
you feel like he's never going to throw
it in that window and they're like what
the hell is he doing like that's tough
to defend
the ball all over the place
what about the super bowl wins uh that
you want to look back on today that
you're particularly proud of about those
teams
malcolm uh man i think i'm i'm proud of
like
not only just the
the championship of like winning what
the sport brings
is
eventually you realize as a team you
know when you carry
the hopes and dreams of an entire city
kind of on your shoulders as the season
goes on and on the pressure builds and
as the context around the the season you
know bills
you realize just how special the game is
not only to us but to everybody so to be
a part of
um two championship seasons with two
different franchises that and it'd be
the first championship in both of those
cities
um
you know it's something special and i
can't describe you know what it is not
like uh i would imagine if it was an
organization like new england that's
expected to win he's done this many
times
um that it's a lot different than new
orleans when you know post katrina and
everything that the city needed they
they used the saints as
you know
a tool for healing and them games meant
something to the city and we carried
that city all the way to a super bowl
and felt the love
um in the
the impact of that win and then for me
to go to another city
very similar fan base that is passionate
loves their team but never had that
championship a hard city to live in you
know where people are
struggling and working it's a very
blue-collar town but that loved their
team
uh with all the social justice stuff
that was happening in philadelphia at
the time you had meek mill and uh and
protest and to be able to bring all of
that to the stage
in front of everybody and beat tom brady
as though we were underdogs and lost our
quarterback to overcome all of that and
really stand as a beacon for
uh really to represent the spirit of
philadelphia and embody the spirit of
philadelphia is is a different
experience that i imagine you know from
just your normal
uh
championship you know game
malcolm jenkins here on the rich eisen
show and as you now leave the game as a
player what's the biggest challenge for
the nfl that you want to put on the
table people should be paying attention
to what you got for me on that front
yeah i think right now the biggest one
is their inability to
uh correct the disparities in um in
coaching you know
it's a very simple solution we want more
black head coaches because we under we
know that there are um
many that are out there that are
qualified and ready to step into the
roles
um and unfortunately you know decades
over the game we haven't seen anything
change in that space and every in every
effort they do roll out seems to only
muddy the waters or make it more
difficult and i think
realistically
um we need to
the the nfl really only responds to one
thing they don't respond to the
principle of the thing they respond to
the press
and the the pressure and i think
people need to continue to raise hell
you know until they move
because
um at the end of the day we it it has to
change and and
it has to change from a cultural
standpoint it can't be about mandating
things and putting one person in place
to suffice you know the hunger of the of
the masses it's like no we want the
entire culture to change and then and
when that happens you have to look at
leadership and if that leadership group
is never going to change
um
you know then
it's really going to be hard to do that
and the only way to truly do that is to
create pressure and i think we've seen
hopefully my career has been an example
of how to do that that there's a road
map of how to do it but it's also been
other
you know examples when we had all the
star players in the league talking about
uh or asking roger goodell to or not
even asking demanding that he apologize
for the treatment of colin kaepernick
that he uh said that he recognizes that
black lives matter and all these things
things that we had to go to war for in
2016 you know he did that got done
overnight and so i think hopefully
players see their role in
uh speaking up on behalf of these
coaches to to get their fair share
but i also think we need to hear from
black coaches as well
and in the fan base to continue to
you know
push the nfl
to
being a more diverse and equitable
equitable place especially one that at
least reflects
um its locker rooms its locker rooms and
its main source of labor malcolm jenkins
here on the day of his announced
retirement on the rich eisen show so we
know about your foundation we've talked
about that other times uh give me an
update on that and what's next for you
what what else is on your plate
yeah
yeah it's um
it's we've been we started in 2010 so
12 years of of
just work in multiple cities and the
good thing is you know it's one of those
things i've always wanted to outlast me
and my fame and it is
one that will continue on far beyond my
playing career and so we've been you
know focused over the last really two
years on uh financial literacy
um opening bank accounts or savings
accounts for uh
school-age children getting them to
understand the the principles of
investing
uh and how to build and grow wealth um
as well as providing uh we want to we've
been building out this digital uh
curriculum this academy for
kids in high school to really get
prepared with other life skills and and
hear from
different
subject matter experts in
uh various amounts of fields that aren't
sure that you don't have to go to a non
traditional four years at a at a college
to get to so when people want to go from
high school right into the workforce we
want to create an academy that is
showing them the road maps to do that in
ways that aren't your traditional uh
pathways and so
those are those have been the main
things that we've been working on trying
to affect as many uh kids and youth as
possible
um and obviously um
we you know my mom is the is the
president of the foundation and the one
who is really
carried this on and so you know as i'm
looking at and reflecting on what we've
been able to do over the last you know
13 years or 10 years for us as a
foundation um i'm proud of not only
myself and my mom
and the the
board um that has really helped me bring
this idea that i had a long time ago to
give back to my community and have an
impact and brought it you know over a
decade
um
to doing some really really impactful
work and affecting thousands of people
and hopefully continuing to do that and
then of course your business interests i
know about your media listen up media
you began your production company
everybody can watch your
your first project the that won best
documentary in the uh a film festival
circuit called black boys you can watch
that right here on peacock um you got a
clothing line too you can start that one
out too
yeah so the clothing line has actually
been around for it'll be five years five
years spring fantastic looking this is
awesome
start we started out with just you know
custom suits and now
uh we do full menswear women's wear
um we've had numerous athletes both nfl
nba wnba uh wearing our stuff you know
styling before the games and things like
that um but we just continue to grow
even this past
um weekend at the oscars had you know a
few celebrities on the red carpet
wearing our stuff so tell me it was
chris rock please tell me it was chris
rock please tell me it was chris ross
we were we weren't part of the main
stage of a moment uh okay we got goals
though okay
that'd have been great spell your name
right damari you know
right that would have been the perfect
no it's
that's one of the things that i've been
excited to grow
um
it's every year it just gets bigger and
bigger and like you said the production
company is really that's my that's where
i'm excited to jump into next i've
always been a storyteller i've always
been somebody who wants to kind of
educate the masses but i've always been
hamstrung by sports media you know like
i still only have access to
you know the sports writers and
platforms that are around me so to
really take advantage of my own voice
both in front of the camera and behind
the camera and tell the stories that i
want in a little bit more creative way
than what people have you know seen for
me in the past and something i'm really
excited about even been writing a uh a
scripted comedy series alongside of a
really good writer named chuck hayward
he's written for
wanda vision and for dear white people
and it's a it's a it's a comedy you know
loosely based around my experience as a
professional athlete and
it's in these kind of creative projects
that i really found my voice and how i
want to
express this new journey i'm on to the
world and that's really you know what
i'm most excited about stepping into
next and obviously the game is something
i love so broadcasting is always in in
in my future being around the game
talking about it is what i love to do i
don't see that changing at all so it's
you know it's a lot of things a lot of
options a lot of a lot of things on the
table
um
and right now you know i'm taking it all
in being in the moment and and really
excited about
um the open in the future well you
always have a place here malcolm jenkins
as you know
i've always enjoyed talking to you as a
player i look forward to doing it
on in the future now that your career is
over i mean two super bowls
three pro bowls 13 seasons 14th overall
pick in the 2009 draft a thousand
tackles and 20 interceptions since
entering the nfl in 2009 over the
thousand tackles nobody else has that
stat line an incredible career for
somebody who came from a basketball
school so big malcolm for you
so
congratulations
you know i appreciate you you know what
i'm surprised uh and i i kudos to you
you're you're a good man of integrity
because i've
i've rubbed it in your face every time
i've been on the show
and and how they you know
they always fall short of victory when i
would i would i would amend the word
always oh no i would amend the word
have to defend it and always know what i
was surprised that all of the people
that i heard from last year uh the great
debacle was uh i didn't hear from you
and i was like you know what
rich is a good man
you know i just people down i just wait
i wait i abide time i lurk that's what
i'm a professional lurker uh malcolm so
but hey you know uh like i said for a
basketball school would have been great
to have michigan ohio state in the sweet
16. we were there
unfortunately you couldn't make it so
we'll just have to do that down the road
just have to do all of that down the
road malcolm
down the road okay malcolm was the only
person you didn't call then during this
little time
i was living my best life
you didn't want any of this smoke is all
i'm basically saying you didn't want you
didn't want that call malcolm
you didn't want that i didn't i was i
didn't remind you i didn't reach out
anything i stated to black myself
anytime malcolm please whatever you want
to do here in la um we've got a place
here i always appreciate you calling in
and uh making my show part of your
playing career and i look forward to
more thanks for the call always
appreciate the support brother right
back at you that's malcolm jenkins there
he is one of the best
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here